all right bullet cav show man special
guest in here it's been a while man
ralphie the plug is here welcome brother
[Music]
program obviously i have not seen you
since your brother passed away
um and y'all had a legendary freestyle
and interview on our show man
that's one of the best freestyles man
that's just some people a lot of people
for sure um but it's good to see you man
how are you bro and i mean like i said
bro i mean
it's been i haven't seen you since that
happened bro so i know that you know
that was a serious uh loss for the city
for your family
um how you hanging in there though i
mean you're active you're dropping music
we staying busy man we just as long as i
stay busy i have my mind that's the only
way my mind is there so by staying in
the studio
staying recording videos [ __ ] i got holy
water [ __ ] i got [ __ ] skateboards and
[ __ ] i got
i love how you decided to do
water instead of soda because
everybody's got a
a fruity ass soda you gotta make sure
everybody out here healthy you
understand like i said what i was
telling you earlier
one day they're gonna look up and i'm
gonna have the only water out there when
the water drow count
i'm gonna be the man i'm gonna be a
[ __ ] multi billionaire
9.0 ph alkaline water it tastes like it
too it does yeah
ain't that it ain't that fossil water up
in the bottom i like that yeah
um but how are you like just dealing
with the loss man um obviously i'm sure
it's
every day is different right mentally
i'm just busy i don't stop i wake up i
go to sleep by dinner four in the
morning i probably wake up at nine eight
you know saying huh
back as soon as i wake up back in the
studio or playing the beat or just
innovating you know saying i wake up
waking these up like what are we doing
here i'm saying like how we finna do
something we gotta do something today
like what's the plot like do you feel
like um
just having like that high workout that
kind of helps you keep your mind off of
the effects off your bro cause if i
ain't like and then every time i look up
just [ __ ] damn you're everybody doing
everything because of him so you gotta
see it so every time i look up and see
something i'm like damn that's crazy
that [ __ ] really started that [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying
cause he innovated a lot of [ __ ]
and he was like the spokesman yeah man i
saw um
i believe is your mom that was putting
the lawsuit together yeah wrongful death
what's the update with that
oh no he's just waiting kobe it was kind
of slowing [ __ ] down right right right
right right right yeah man well [ __ ] bro
i feel like you've definitely done a
great job of
keeping the truth alive
keeping it going man
and i feel like when you rap like people
you're you know you're you're your
brother's brother no cat and uh gene
he come from the same field like you
know i'm saying most people don't
understand like they're like oh you
sound like draco no like we literally
made this [ __ ] up together like yeah
he was just popping first not me
it's still the same slang like you know
i'm saying it's all
if he make a word up or i make a word up
or catch you make a word up it's all the
same like you understand come from the
same it's just whoever put on the song
first
yeah i mean i told this to his face
multiple times that that's on video that
like just in terms of like uh a lot of
what's going on especially when he went
to jail a lot of people got got on with
his style so okay so basically l.a rap
you would say he brought
the flu flaming nervous music i brought
like the
the
pimp
slash finesse [ __ ] music like you know
what i'm saying i talk like more about
like
you know i'm saying like
jigging [ __ ] with juice and
pills and [ __ ] and like
selling [ __ ] for the high or just
getting money from a [ __ ] from perky
meat and getting back from the size of a
[ __ ] jergens and he more like
flew flamma up if he
staring at my jewelry right now
maybelline bopping chili for chili baba
like you know saying like he more like
artistic with it i'm more like i just
say what it is you want some player [ __ ]
when you say perky meat what are we
talking about i'm serving that park you
mean if they got the feed you know i'm
like you know bigelow around this
[ __ ] i've never done um
i've only smoked weed and done shrooms
never done any pills i only do drugs
that people prescribe and that people
can um that's actually tested and that
you can do outside like i said i do
drugs that we can do on live not that we
gotta hide i've heard uh though
there's something about having sex on
percocet yeah wearing [ __ ] out off
the park she's like oh
here keep going i got a bonus for you
is it like kind of like doing like this
is like on some viagra [ __ ]
i mean it's just like a perk but like
it's just a perk to me a perk is just
like
i guess you can say it is but
i don't do the perfect for that type of
[ __ ] i just see what i'm saying it's all
about the music again are you ever
worried about uh
you know the fentanyl [ __ ] getting the
wrong batch [ __ ] yeah i'm saying i got a
couple old heads on the roster you gotta
other than that uh we ain't doing no no
fenty's no pressies yeah i saw like now
people are i'm one that had fetty wap
now people are uh they don't even want
they want they no give me the fentanyl
yeah that's what i'm not eating crack
this [ __ ] is wild out here bro
yeah it's like [ __ ] are smoking
fentanyl like it's normal yeah like it's
just a thing
super crackheads is what i call them
like if you're gonna do like all that
type of [ __ ] you better are doing
shrooms like i'll be trying to tell
people like if you want to just
act like you want to go to another power
then just take some streams you're going
to be out you know i'm saying don't be
like overdo it just kind of micro dose
until that [ __ ] stop hitting 10 micro
dos a little more you know sin but don't
most people would do strums and just
like oh it's not hitting me well take
more you gotta eat more you know what
i'm saying yeah or then there's people
who will do it and then like in 15
minutes they'd be like it hasn't hit me
yet and then they eat more and i'm like
bro give it 30. yeah you got to give it
a while because now you're [ __ ] yeah
because same thing with like an edible
you eat edible and
you your life will be ruined 60 minutes
later like me with shrooms i'm not
trying to see nothing i'm just trying to
like send vibe
have you ever had a heart like a crazy
trip on trooms though not because i only
micro dose
and then i only do the chocolate i don't
really [ __ ] with all that stuff because
[ __ ] there's actual shrooms
cause they taste terrible yeah i don't
know what to mix it with yeah they're
they taste like
old dusty sunflower seeds some people
like all people be like oh yeah you
should just do the regular like that's
your week what up y'all gotta stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our good folks over at blue chew now
fellas if you're out there and you're
suffering from a little bit of that ed
erectile dysfunction it's totally normal
it happens you could be stressed out at
work you could be
just having anxiety in life and uh you
know your dick is not up to par well
guess what that's where blue chew comes
in because blue chew
has the same active ingredients as
viagra and escialis and check this out
it's a straight online prescription
service you do not have to go to the
doctor's office you don't have to go
have any like weird awkward
conversations about why your dick isn't
working with a stranger no what you do
is
you go to bluechew.com
use the promo code bootleg and you'll
get your first month for
free that's right first month for free
all you do is pay five dollars shipping
all right and when i tell you that
bluetooth it hits all right you will uh
you'll be [ __ ] like you never [ __ ]
before let's just say that shout out to
uh bluechu one more time get your first
month free use the promo code bootleg
bluechew.com it comes right to your door
in discrete packaging open it up it's in
a chewable form and it is that [ __ ] to
fight ed so go to bluetooth.com asap and
use that promo code bootleg and try it
for a month for free yo you've uh
recently been uh
in a mix-up online with uh adam
what happened with uh with the adam
thing obviously you know
like i just i don't i don't got a
problem saying the truth but seem like
every time i say the truth people get
mad i hit him up i told him i'm like
that's um what's funny because t-rell
was at my
show and he was like i gotta go cause i
gotta go interview ralphie
yeah he called me but i mean he text me
and then i called me so whatever that
day was t-ro was here that day doing an
interview with me so
he takes me a long paragraph telling my
smile you're gonna come you're not
caught i mean that's you know i don't do
all the texts right right right right if
you take me like that's like my [ __ ]
text me i'm gonna look like
you're gonna have to call me six times
now because now as if it's right you
know what i'm saying but
no i called him an answer so i just left
like that but uh not adam i told that
[ __ ] like i tried my g say he to homie
so
if you the homie and you say you [ __ ]
with us how you [ __ ] with us
why has it been so long it's like all
right so three months after draco died i
hit him up like [ __ ] damn they like you
know what i'm saying like can i pay for
some promo like [ __ ] [ __ ] you to hug me
if you don't help me you're supposed to
just be posting it so obviously i feel
like you ain't doing nothing so you're
saying essentially three months after he
died no not even that i'm just going
crazy no no but like you're putting out
so much music and and what you're
griping i made a pop album that went
number 25. it's essentially
why why am i not seeing my stuff being
promoted on unless you keep laughing
everybody so i just like i hit him up
i'm like all right
you uh i said how much do i got to pay
you to get like some weekly promo he's
like oh you ain't got to pay me it's
good
all right good luck and appreciate it if
he would have did it you know what i'm
saying good looking he never said that
so then
i think it was like april or something
i'm like damn what's up like you don't
[ __ ] you y'all anti-sting team man no
jumper you know i'm saying like what
y'all [ __ ] with the homies or something
you're like oh well
he hit me up my dm on twitter like oh we
got to clear something up what's your
number i sent him my number didn't text
me don't hit me up so now i caught i
mean now it's two weeks later i'm just
like [ __ ] you're just a hug like yeah
i'm saying like i ain't gonna keep
asking you for to pay reminds you i
gotta ask you to pay for bromo you know
yeah i know he doesn't uh
personally run that page no he responded
to me i hit him up on adam 22. no i mean
i mean the no jumper page
oh my
[Laughter]
it's a lot going on on that neck man
yeah yeah man but now like i was saying
i hit him up so then he you know saying
he said what he said i said what i said
well hopefully i mean i know um
ain't nothing like i just said what i
said with your anti yeah no no i know i
know it's nothing like serious but i
just know that adam obviously had a lot
of love for your brother and uh i feel
like he just got people i mean he
literally he kind of
said like they fake bullying i'm like
you know baby baby old me when i be
posting long live the ruler he's got
he's got a lot of [ __ ] uh like that no i
mean that ig page the quote unquote no
jump right g page is ran by like four
different people yeah but no jumpers
kind of like
really stink team shoreline greedo fans
you know what i'm saying you got a la
based podcast why do you think all your
comments are stink team you know
you post somebody that we don't like you
get a hundred stink team comments in the
rest box you know what i'm saying so
for you to act like you don't have to
play a role with this [ __ ] draco gone
you know i'm saying basically you don't
need this yeah you know what i'm saying
so for your platform you already built
that um
and his oh well i was the only one that
talked about y'all yes because it was
only when i gave you a platform so when
draco went to jail he was the topic of
your your platform you know i'm saying
don't make it seem like you were the
only one talking about you only talk
about what's to talk about that's what
you do you're a podcast you get i'm
saying yeah i think he was probably the
biggest
to talk about it but you know shout out
to like guys like you know my guy rose
clans vic like there was a lot of people
who was um definitely
kind of documenting
them like probably twice you know i'm
saying we was in trial for three years
and you're saying it's like
what is the um
i just see him talking about thug and
[ __ ] ten times already
yeah you know like let's be
crazy that [ __ ] is crazy the young thug
situation is
free slime and you know man
it's like no matter how big you are then
they're watching bro yeah cause i'm glad
they did our [ __ ] early you know what
i'm saying but you're on another note
yeah man i'm signing artists i got old
team and i'm signing producers i got
legend um
[ __ ] who else uh under the stink team
umbrella right now artist-wise uh otm
otm young boyhood trophy
[ __ ] finesse
say so
by the way i just noticed the crash band
is that crash bandicoot crash bandicoot
you know we crash bandicoot coupe so we
crash and abandon the coop you know what
i'm saying
yo so can you kind of give give me like
um a little insight on like what
happened with ramble
i mean [ __ ] nothing i mean i guess he
took it personal because he thought
wanted to hunt me he said something
about them but they didn't you know i'm
saying they were just rapping like we
all rapped right right right right bars
and bars
have meanings but he thought that
meaning was for him you know i'm saying
and it wasn't so he was wrong he hit the
little [ __ ] up and they said what they
said right so and then he hit me up and
then you know what i'm saying i told him
i knew you hit me you ain't hit me at
first and then be like you know what i'm
saying like why you say that or is they
talking about me no you went straight
and went for the kill after your homies
already hit a month so i mean y'all was
talking about it and [ __ ] like why you
don't hit me up don't hit me up to
alleviate it now like it ain't it ain't
nothing
so for a [ __ ] to be like
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] i ain't [ __ ] with y'all
if y'all [ __ ] with them type [ __ ]
i ain't sup
you know what i'm saying what you
thought jewish i guess he probably
thought he was like super big dog you
know after draco da everybody the city
was that for grabs so you know what i'm
saying
nobody grabbed it just said bus like
it's not our fault
so i guess [ __ ] be kind of feeling
some type of way but that ain't got
nothing to do with me did it feel like
um
did you kind of
you know obviously during that time
you're probably grieving but did you
kind of see people trying to move in to
try to take that crown yeah no it was if
it was it wasn't oblivious like yeah it
wasn't
it wasn't like i didn't see nothing
because in terms of just like having
having like i mean i'll say this like uh
there's certain stuff that i'll post
online and it's like
can't post certain stuff with certain
artists without a ton of comments
you know
so it's like about about your brother
you know what i mean like
my thing is
nobody can be mad at us because we went
on crunch time
when the time came
y'all thought we were just gonna go sit
in the house and you know i'm saying boo
boo cry
no
we still on the same [ __ ] because draco
didn't die you know shoot out no crazy
street [ __ ] like how the [ __ ] we be on
you know what i'm saying he died at work
you know what i'm saying at his job you
know what i'm saying [ __ ] make it seem
like oh he died on something
no he died at work where he felt more
comfortable mm-hmm we didn't die on the
street you know i'm saying he didn't die
on the street period
so as far as the
the program we didn't change nothing you
know saying they expected us to change
the program
no why would we change you know saying
we wasn't doing nothing wrong
yeah i mean
i think like
yeah just what happened man so
unfortunate bro because you would think
like you said
in that type of setting everybody's so
gangster you're going to sing [ __ ]
just tripping you know what i'm saying
you would think all the pop ups we did
you know all the shows we did [ __ ]
just like you know what i'm saying
but that's another note yeah was there
any like when you guys uh got to that
show was there any idea that there was
any like like like you guys said you're
at work
we wasn't worried about we went to work
you know what i'm saying we wasn't
caring who was there who was that man we
just went to work you know i'm saying
draco's gonna pick up his money if it
was just me him and
one security he wasn't giving [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying would you say that
the
backstage area was a bit
unorganized for five minutes that's what
i mean like that's crazy to think you
guys were there for five minutes and and
that popped off so i can only imagine
like in terms of you guys lack of
security security like wait wait wait i
know security if you ask me [ __ ] i ain't
seen uh
unless it was at the front searching our
security that's the only place i see in
security is that kind of the or like
kind of the premise of
uh your guys's lawsuit just kind of the
lack of security or lack of organization
i wouldn't know [ __ ] that should be the
premise of the you know thing because
that's what it was i didn't see no
security other than
where they checked draco security that
was it
that's crazy man
man
i know you and your brother got a lot of
unreleased music
well i know the way he recorded um
i mean damn dude i remember i was just
so blown away by the time like he got
out he was out for like a month and it
felt like he put out five albums
you know what i'm saying and i was right
behind our team now yeah it's crazy like
your you guys is uh just like i said
though uh uh what i was saying uh
he can drop
one song and do a million plays
i used to have to drop 10 songs to do a
million plays you know what i'm saying
just add up to his one
now i got the same formula but i'm doing
almost the same place as he was doing
before
so as now it's like i'm just
flooding the internet like my youtube
probably got what like 30 million
streams just in the last what two three
months that's just crazy like just off
of content most people want one video to
do 30 million stream
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] if i got 20
videos that i dropped and they all got
two three hundred thousand it's only
been
a month
it ain't even been a whole year i got
200 some videos that ain't even been out
for a year yet you know what i'm saying
you see you got 200 videos 235 probably
videos that's right
you know what i'm saying plus tapes like
yeah i'm saying how many full projects
do you say that you got out right now
four how many four prizes i dropped this
year five five so far
one of them being a pop project one was
a pop now i'm going to double back with
iron rafi too
and then uh i mean i roughly deluxe and
um
skateboard p deluxe i dropped
pastor ralphie two pass raffy two deluxe
uh
what most consistent i did that like one
day
uh [ __ ]
uh
i don't even know i just skateboard p
[ __ ] i got too much [ __ ]
hey we got to stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our good folks
at odd socks listen the most comfortable
socks in the entire world i promise you
are these odd socks basics right here
now i like the uh the uh high joints the
whites or the blacks
we're very inclusive at the bootleg head
podcast love the blacks and the whites
of odd socks of course um but they also
got the crazy licenses they got ninja
turtles they got a [ __ ] scarface
breaking bad socks which i just
rewatched amazing and their underwear
the best man i was just talking to
somebody about how fire the odd socks
draws are because the waistband don't
fold they're just comfy as hell so go to
odd socks
official.com you see the website spell
it that same way and use the promo code
bootleg cab all one word together and
you'll get 20
off from our presenting sponsors our
family at odd socks it's all that's on
my ass and feet ladies and gentlemen so
we'll get you some odd socks let's get
back to the interview um
how are you guys going to handle
releasing some of your brother's
unreleased [ __ ] [ __ ] i run this [ __ ]
hold on
[ __ ] i just drop them i'ma try to like
get certain songs cleared and kind of
just like try to get some features
together get to promote yeah yeah it's
not like me dropping
me dropping draco so i got it and we got
his instagram so i really gotta like
push it push it do you um
well you guys don't have access to the
ig nah but we can get it what y'all said
yeah i'm sure there's some channels to
go through yeah yeah um
do you uh
you know
what i loved about draco was his
he was very hell-bent on staying
independent yeah yeah cause he could
have done he could have went somewhere
and got a crazy advance and you know
just had him right but uh you know he
stayed independent um i know he was
discussing doing like a stink situation
i think it might have been with him was
it that was that was empire
[ __ ] with nobody um but in terms of uh
your [ __ ] are you still on that are you
on that same
wavelength like not signing yeah like i
said i've been owning this thing team
llc since 2007. i just mean in terms of
like now that you're heating up like at
a level that you never have before like
is it saying distinct team nlc i've been
having since 2016.
so if like atlantic came at you tomorrow
you're not interested 30 million you
know what i'm saying because i got
producers i got artists i got a
structure i got i got holy water you
know what i'm saying and it tastes good
man like you know saying i got
skateboards merch they can't get none of
that they only come in for my catalog
well they can't even get that y'all can
only get my new catalog
yeah they want to they're going to win
all the back [ __ ] and 60 bands a month
yeah off of just just distro kid you
know what i'm saying that's great
another 13. you know saying merch
another probably 15.
there's nothing they can give me
like nothing
i'm on whip three right now i got info
you are a hell of a skateboarder
there are some great rapping skaters uh
hopson is one of them
uh rich the kid
uh
[Applause]
i don't know about wayne but i know
hobson i know hobson's like a serious
ears he still can't kick flip i know
hopson's like a serious skateboarder
like i'm like getting a couple [ __ ]
maybe it's a couple other ones too but i
don't be i'll just be seeing when they
post my bike uh uh
little nary hard nars fire yeah uh
phoenix r
uh
like i'm better than phoenix are you are
you pretty active at scale like you
still [ __ ] play skating just [ __ ]
around or not yeah i go to the park
every day and then i say i hope too i'll
be hoping
i dunk on that [ __ ] your knees can't
[ __ ] me
he said
skating and hooping skating hooping [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] over i'm just professional
i'm finna start boxing
[ __ ] i'm finna do it all i got my own
weed [ __ ] i got [ __ ] i got brands of
weeds you could definitely get the uh
ralphie county plug if
i mean there's definitely a bag to get
in the boxing world oh yeah i'm finna
knock some spell
i already seen like
like the boxing world and like
half your fights is like [ __ ] even
if you just fight like a fight fight a
youtuber or something just [ __ ] mop
him up man i want to do it for real
that's [ __ ] you want to actually fight
like some jake paul [ __ ] like you like
condition up and like get with it like
you know what i'm saying the only uh
rapper who i know can like really really
buy i know there's guys who could fight
and i know there's guys who could box
too i take that back but like you know d
smoke
from inglewood d smoke he won the uh
netflix show
that [ __ ] is a boxer boxer
where do you say his room
uh
he's from eagle with sir sir from td's
bro he's a good guy good guy d smoke
don't even matter yeah he can fight for
real yeah him and g perico just bought a
broadway boxing gym
yeah nice guy man who are outside of the
stinks who are you [ __ ] with in the
city like i mean obviously
the city i mean nobody really [ __ ] with
us just seem like we just like yeah you
guys are kind of like on an island but
it seemed like everybody outside of our
island [ __ ] with us see what i'm saying
everybody outside there they know the
truth
everybody in there like can't take the
truth like you know what i'm saying why
do you think that it is bad
like i said i was telling homes
if they never accepted that draco was
the truth they're never going to accept
that we the truth like you know ever so
because i felt like even when you got to
deal with it yeah i felt like even when
draco got out like it felt like you guys
were very much like on an island very
much we still on that same mountain
anti-industry but then guys like drake
would tap in or you know that's why i
said everybody outside l.a
understands the presence of the stink
team like that's why we got so many
features with everybody like you know
what i'm saying
detroit
the peasy [ __ ] the yeah yeah detroit
[ __ ] with you man like certain areas
[ __ ] what it's like and it's just like
how the [ __ ] does we got all this reach
without paying [ __ ] and having to pay
in clear features and
how does all these people like oh yeah i
clear his song
but the [ __ ] in the city not like oh
that's less work like yeah what do you
think it is about detroit that like
really it's it's a hustler's city like
you know i'm saying and we give hustler
revives like you know what i'm saying
like we don't we not the average
turk dancing and riding all those type
of [ __ ] like we more like like let's
get this money like
you're not getting money we don't want
to talk so
it's easier to like brand would i guess
you know what i'm saying that's fair uh
you said on twitter a lot of people it
went viral that the boys album is better
than kendrick's album that's me i
listened to the boy album and guess what
music is subjective exactly
subjective no it is it is it like at the
end of the day
nobody can talk [ __ ] about someone's
opinion exactly if that's your opinion
see but most people that gave their
opinion on my opinion didn't listen to
the album they just gave their opinion
based off of kendrick's old [ __ ] like
all kendra's to go don't don't say that
about kendra all right did you listen to
it no you ain't listening to it because
if you listen to it you'll see what i'm
saying because i listen to the boy [ __ ]
one through
eleven or whatever number it is and i
listen to his [ __ ] one through eleven i
got more vibes off of more songs
on this album than this one you can't
tell me i you know you can't change that
in my head
literally yeah you can't and you can't
just go throwing his album in front of
people after five years like he's just
the messiah rap like like that's just
realistic especially when you got [ __ ]
like the homies and [ __ ] dropping [ __ ]
back to back all he knows skips like you
know what i'm saying
i'm not feeling did you like the
kendrick i'm at all
i listened to the whole tape
one song was like you know what i'm
saying okay i see what the world right
you know i'm saying two songs the one
with kodak it was like all right you
gotta know that you put a [ __ ] like a
real [ __ ]
a couple of other ones just like two
like like
you know what i'm saying like
barber shop
oh [ __ ] vibe like you can't stand like
boogie joint like you know what i'm
saying like like
like it's that [ __ ] at the barber shop
politic music and
picnics with the family and let me put
on my headphones and do my homework i
don't want nobody some people need that
though i'm not saying it's wrong right
but you can't just say that's better
because the message he pushing
i still got to deliver it a certain way
i think i think like
by the way the boys project is very
slept on not being talked about enough
shout out to the whole bay shout out to
vallejo um
but i just think like
in terms of
people got to stop taking uh music
opinions personal bro like if i feel a
certain way no because if i don't say
[ __ ] like this then people will just be
in the matrix
they just gonna be like oh they said
this is hot
so this is hot
oh well this is cool they just gonna go
with it like the everyday program how
they wake up and go to work every day
cut on the radio it's a program so
if a [ __ ] like me don't say something
the program continues like you get what
i'm saying
i gotta say so without the program you
get what i'm saying
people [ __ ] with me without the
independent push the labels and [ __ ] so
if people [ __ ] me that mean i gotta say
so so when i say something like i listen
to this tape and this tape too this one
was better
people be like
man he's man [ __ ] that why that [ __ ]
say that you know i said if i was nobody
[ __ ] just should be like
sleeping under right right but since
like oh this [ __ ] making noise he
dropping [ __ ] back to back
why he say that why he not a part of the
program it's kendrick turner he's
dropping you know what i'm saying why we
it's time to push kendra
like no bro she was cool you know what
i'm saying it well he's not weak
his his his his the way he used words is
good right but that doesn't mean it's
appealing to everybody like that i don't
mean this yeah sonic it's it's
definitely uh an album that if someone
told me sonically it's not for them i
can't even be mad at you i'm like yo i
haven't been in i haven't been in
probably
30 rooms
with over 20 people
and nobody downloaded it so you're not
going to put out this perception like he
just broke the internet
with his music stream you know what i'm
saying that's what i mean by i love the
album but it's good but yeah it's i
you're not going to be like he's the
messiah rap it's been five years that
album was the the savior right right
right no who's in a month
nobody's gonna be talking about none of
them songs right
now
i might be slapping some of that [ __ ]
off the boy [ __ ] like in traffic just
getting money like
in a couple months because i'll be off
some [ __ ] boy i'll be on that [ __ ] i'll
be trying to get that bag you understand
it just devised to get off and they
rolling up what smoke camp man i'm
saying they get past me
we rolled [ __ ] like you know what i'm
saying
like [ __ ] like that what inspired you to
do uh the pop [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] uh physical [ __ ] that's how
some [ __ ] you can't make no [ __ ] like
this so i'm like man [ __ ] gotta play a
beating you understand just start really
freestyling like man with this [ __ ] like
i'm the type of [ __ ] i listen to every
music that's why i got an opinion
because when i say kendrick album was
all right that's because i listened to
lyrical people before all the way from
most deaf knives jaded kids right you
know i'm saying uh hospital earl
sweatshirt you know i'm saying like all
the way to
the the the [ __ ] wu team like you
know
dip said and [ __ ] like you know i'm
saying biggie like you're not going to
push that [ __ ] on me though you know
what i'm saying
all the way to j cole so
you're not going to just be like
this is the messiah [ __ ] like he he just
saved the game
no hell no now listen that [ __ ] was
alright the boys feels better you know
what i'm saying
only reason i said that because they
dropped on the same day they did drop
the same day now me i'm not the [ __ ] to
just be dick riding [ __ ] i don't even
listen to the tapes that dropped that
day
i'm not talking about myself you know
what i'm saying i'm not saying [ __ ] all
my [ __ ] better because to me i'm so
eager i think all my [ __ ] better you
know i'm saying so for me to say
this [ __ ] tape is [ __ ] [ __ ] i said
what i said you know what i'm saying but
not a pop [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
i'm trying to uh i went i would the
[ __ ] fizzle made to be right i went
crazy
then i did two songs a day i think it
was riding my wave
um
[ __ ]
riding my wave and shot of that whiskey
because it was supposed to be a fake
country
country pop
no cap it was supposed to be fake
country but then the songs start getting
like halfway r b right you know what i'm
saying so when they start getting r b
i kind of like all right let me stop
making them for a while like i can't
picture you listening to country
yeah i got some pretty country [ __ ]
what's your go-to country [ __ ] if
you're listening what's an artist that
you actually like in the country i mean
that's a very like okay like i just know
songs that i know like that i heard like
just on the radio like all right so in
jail you hear every music right you know
i'm saying so
everything that play [ __ ] i didn't
heard [ __ ] all the way from
going down to the honky tonk to the all
the way down to the you know saying uh
uh
what's that other one that [ __ ] said um
but
all the way to kings leon you know i'm
saying even [ __ ] i don't think he's
comfortable he's like kind of pop kings
leon's not country but it's pop but yeah
they're hard yeah but like that's the
same station right like they gonna mix
all that [ __ ] you know
they're gonna play kings leon they're
gonna play like the shawn mendes they're
gonna play like the
the justin biebers and the the that
what's her name uh
[Music]
yeah man
i wish i had my earphones on right now
i'll be like i'll just be off the splash
but i know the song yeah and i got too
much of the artists like you know i'm
saying uh so you got a a lot more music
that you plan on releasing the rest of
the year
i got too much music i probably i got
i got faux tapes ready right now like i
can just drop them like that's crazy
[ __ ] fo five i got stinks got off the
muscle done i got
skateboard p deluxe down ir rafi deluxe
i got
um doing them so cold
and probably a rapper overnight three
but their songs is ready like you know
i'm saying like
the only thing that's not ready
for something to take this cover art
right right right but pretty much i'm
ready like you gotta get the covers the
videos all that good [ __ ] together
what is uh is there any plan like soon
to get any of
any of your brothers unreleased [ __ ] out
i'm supposed to we're supposed to be
doing some [ __ ] this summer
but like if i can't get most of them
songs [ __ ] he don't need features i like
his [ __ ] better without features like
you know what i'm saying yeah because i
mean
is it hard i mean obviously with him not
being here i'm sure he had some big
features he was sitting on now to see
the features it's more like your [ __ ]
just like all right guys we going clear
just because you know what i'm saying
like [ __ ] guys on major labels
that's weird yeah i'm saying
like oh i mean i guess you probably
can't say who are some of the unreleased
features no he got a gang [ __ ] he got
like he got features with everybody he
probably got
like the songs that i got he got like a
playboy cardi verse he got like those
zuma verbs quite well
money man i swear
uh
um i think
[ __ ] a peasy verse
we got a shy grizzy version i'm sure all
the independent stuff will be easy to
clear yeah for sure oh ozuna though
yeah for sure that's crazy that's tg
you gotta um
it's a bunch of the plug versus uh
[ __ ]
[ __ ] he got a little bit everything
right you know i'm saying what do you
feel like um it's because to me it's
kind of crazy that like uh
what happened to your brother happened
where it happened with as many people
being around and the fact that like
there still hasn't been anybody putting
cuffs
um
they don't like this police don't like
it do you say do you feel like the
like investigation or the i mean do you
feel like the police is not going to
care cause they don't care they don't
like this thing team we beat like
targets you know sam drake will be like
twice i'd be like once we beat up a
whole indictment is it still i mean
obviously is it still an active
investigation trying to figure out what
happened like i mean you were there and
they would say it is but i i don't you
know what i'm saying like
i don't really talk about that type of
[ __ ] yeah no it's crazy man um well
listen bro you killing it
i love to see how active you're being
you're dropping a ton of quality music
keyword is quality okay because a lot of
people could drop a lot of [ __ ]
but i don't mean just listening yeah
that's what i was saying people be like
oh you dropping too much i'm like okay
well let me know and it stopped being
cool like you know yeah let me know when
it's trash listening
then go listen to my pop tape for a
minute don't say switch it up and then
when i totally do a [ __ ] 360 backflip
don't be like oh this is not cool i you
switched it up too much like [ __ ] down
it makes sense how um like if somebody
wanted to try to get your attention to
get signed like what what what are you
looking for like what do you look for in
an artist work ethic you know i'm saying
you got to be working like how i work
you got to work like how old team
workout my producers work like you know
i'm saying like i can't be the only one
going in and you think you're gonna just
attach yourself to what i got going on
if you're not trying to
uh make your presence known yourself are
you understand you gotta drop the videos
you gotta put yourself
in people's faces to where people not
just looking at you as
the new dude from the stink team you
know i'm saying they gotta be looking at
you it's like oh yeah he got a presence
now we [ __ ] like it's like a collab
because i'm not ta i'm not stripping
nobody from
they
write certain you know i'm saying they
music none actually i'm only doing 80 i
mean 20
i'm letting them keep 80. so it's like
you're really just getting the
mentorship you're really just getting
you give me money for from me showing
you this sauce like you know i'm saying
that's not a bad deal yeah that's what
i'm saying i'm 80 20.
i got two producers two artists you
understand so
that's the start that's why i said
you really just kind of paid for the
sauce exactly because if you work like
me and i got 20 with 10 people i got 100
200 you know what i'm saying
so
i think [ __ ] [ __ ] if you work like me
it's good yeah you know what i'm saying
there it is man um well i appreciate you
coming through bro for sure and we got
another freestyle coming oh yeah
different youtube video yeah
you know i brought up this time the last
one was legendary
no cab i got otn man probably pull up
one of these beats for my producers
legend yeah i'm saying go crazy one time
anything else you want to plug man uh
[ __ ] man go get some of this holy water
some of my merch stink team forever.com
follow me on [ __ ] twitter outfit
youtube ralphie the plug on instagram
the plug by ralphie
i feel like you've gone through a couple
igs too yeah that's something i'm like
instagram foe yeah
they keep getting my [ __ ] the leaders
shadow banding me like that [ __ ] weak
yeah how many watches do you have one
right now about three this one's worth
50 now yeah i've mastered this sky
dweller just the cardi with the big
diamonds like 25.
just in terms of like practicality why
wear three watches i don't want to flex
on the wall okay because i can't come to
an interview let me throw three off
yeah they ain't seen me in a while so
every time i gotta make sure they see me
out do you actually tell the time on any
of these watches because you just pulled
the iphone out three or three watches on
my wrist still going on top
still don't tell time i said some flies
[ __ ] i don't even remember saying so
much [ __ ]
i look at what you have three watching
on my wrist still look at the phone for
my time or some [ __ ] some fly [ __ ] like
that
there it is man raffi the plug
appreciate your time bro
boom all right we're gonna let it roll
man that's gonna end the great